[Musique]
un multimilliardaire québécois pour qui
l'argent pouvait tout acheter
[Musique]
jusqu'en 2006 il payait en argent et en
cadeau des adolescentes pour avoir des
rapports sexuels et les entraînaient
dans un sinistre engrenage recruté
toujours plus de jeunes filles donc
c'est une présente une amie je vais
donner 1000 dollars
à peu près
des maisons à Westmount et une suite
dans un hôtel luxueux de Montréal loué à
l'année pour y amener les jeunes filles
un de ses employés m'avaient dit
je comprends pas pourquoi ça dérange que
des [__] dans sa chambre des [__] de
quoi tu parles ce sont des enfants
a toujours nié le secret est resté
enterré pendant des années jusqu'à
aujourd'hui des femmes ont
courageusement accepté de parler à nos
journalistes Brigitte Noël et Pascal
Turbide qui ont creusé cette affaire
pendant des mois c'est comme tu te sens
toute seule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une femme m'a appelé femme elle a dit
il paraît que vous êtes le détective le
plus honnête que je pourrais trouver
2006 Vermont États-Unis avec son
partenaire un détective privé de
Montréal va rencontrer une femme de
Montréal dans un hôtel à Burlington
elle nous a donné rendez-vous au Vermont
elle a dit qu'elle avait trop peur
d'aller à Montréal qu'elle était
terrifiée par son ex-mari X
la cliente
sur la conduite sexuelle de son ex-mari
du matériel pornographique et elle
disait avoir été horrifié
elle voulait qu'on surveille son mari
pour découvrir ce qui se passe
John Wesley est devenu détective privé
après 34 ans au service de la police de
Montréal il n'en est pas à sa première
enquête matrimoniale mais rien ne
pouvait le préparer à celle qu'il allait
entreprendre
[Musique]
la cible de l'enquête n'est pas le
premier venu il s'agit d'un homme
d'affaires alors président fondateur
d'une multinationale basée à Montréal
[Musique]
appartient à Robert Miller c'est l'un
des plus gros distributeurs de
composants électroniques de la planète
et une des sociétés les plus secrètes du
Québec ces vents atteignent 2 milliards
de dollars par année elle emploie 5000
personnes dans le monde dont 1500 à son
siège social de pointecler près de
Montréal
et son fondateur font rarement les
manchettes peu d'articles peu de photos
Robert Miller est un homme très discret
[Musique]
selon le site internet de Ford sa
fortune s'élève aujourd'hui après de 2
milliards de dollars américains il
serait l'un des hommes les plus riches
au Québec et même au Canada
est venues sont difficiles à retracer
et l'image de sa luxueuse résidence de
Westmount est brouillé sur Google Street
View
[Musique]
où sommes-nous en ce moment
sur l'avenue wood une fois sur
Sherbrooke on tourne à droite
John dans les rues de ce quartier huppé
de Montréal
[Musique]
on l'a vu entre ici on a cru qu'il
allait au resto
cette porte de garage s'est ouverte et
hop il est entré après mes employés
garer sur la rue Olivier l'ont vu sortir
de cette maison traverser la rue et
entrer en face ça nous a pris par
surprise on a dû se réorganiser
[Musique]
la voiture de Robert disparaît donc dans
ce garage lié à cette maison qui lui
appartient ce qui surprend c'est qu'il
sort en se parle avant traverse la rue
et entre dans celle-ci le 380 avenue
Olivier
utilise donc deux autres maisons à
seulement 5 minutes en auto de son
domicile les détectives organisent la
surveillance de cette propriété
[Musique]
après 3 ou 4 jours mon équipe et moi
étions stupéfait parce qu'il se passe
tous les soirs après 17 18h on voyait
des femmes entrer et sortir de la maison
[Musique]
on
ne savait pas non
selon leur rapport les détectives
surveillent pendant trois semaines 14
fois ils observent des jeunes femmes
entrées et sortir de la maison alors que
Robert est à l'intérieur 19 jeunes
femmes les détectives réussissent à en
identifier quelques-unes comme celle-ci
dans la vingtaine mais la filature
révèle aussi au moins une mineure de 17
ans
clairement il y avait des jeunes filles
16 17 ans je ne sais pas mais elles
avaient vraiment l'air jeune
que se passe-t-il dans cette maison quel
âge avait les autres jeunes filles
l'avocat de Robert Miller nous a dit que
ce dernier n'est pas en mesure de nous
accorder une entrevue il serait trop
malade au dernier stade de la maladie de
Parkinson
les réponses à nos questions vont donc
devoir nous venir directement des femmes
qui lui ont rendu visite sur l'avenue
Olivier ou ailleurs
[Musique]
on sait que les filles qui entraient
sortaient toujours avec des sacs
c'est sûr il avait un entrepôt pleine
vêtements dans l'ouest de Lille on peut
supposer que tous ces trucs venaient de
là
[Musique]
en effet les détectives observent et
cette jeune femme mettre un sac de
acquis dans sa voiture à cette entrepôt
de pointe clair le contenu de ces sacs
d'or qui joue un rôle important dans
cette histoire nous le découvrirons plus
tard
avenue Olivier John Wesley que son
équipe remarque aussi d'autres hommes
qui s'affairent autour des deux maisons
c'est à ce moment-là que la situation se
complique pour les détectives ils ont
été repérés
par deux membres de sa sécurité
qui travaillait directement pour lui
un modèle
nous nous sommes rencontrés dans un
resto dans l'ouest de Montréal
ils nous ont posé des questions genre on
sait que tu enquêtes sur notre patron
James est-ce que on peut en parler
je leur ai dit que je n'avais pas grand
chose à dire j'ai dit mais qu'est-ce que
vous foutez ici j'ai mis fin à la
rencontre et nous sommes partis
entre-temps lors d'une soirée entre amis
John Wesley s'aperçoit qu'il n'est pas
le seul à connaître les secrets de
Robert Miller
[Musique]
après la pause une suite à l'hôtel
intercontinentale où les filles se
succèdent
j'espérais voir au moins une fille
pleurait pour pouvoir lui offrir mon
aide
à la fin des années 90 Robert Miller
fait venir des jeunes filles dans sa
luxueuse suite à l'hôtel
Intercontinental à Montréal une chambre
qui a même fait modifier à ses frais
[Musique]
la voici l'ami de John Wesley elle est
revenue à Montréal à notre demande
aujourd'hui elle vit ailleurs mais elle
tenait à nous raconter ce qu'elle a vu
ici à la fin des années 90
je m'appelle donaloupret et j'étais
directrice la sécurité de l'hôtel
Intercontinental à Montréal
on est responsable de la sécurité des
clients et des employés
elle revient à l'Intercontinental pour
la première fois depuis longtemps
[Musique]
elle entre dans la suite 2520 qu'elle
reconnaît sans mal c'est encore pareil
et voici le bain le fameux bain
le nom qu'on lui avait donné et
dégoûtant
comment vous l'appelez
c'est assez vulgaire
[Musique]
le facteur
le bain de la base
j'espérais voir au moins une fille
pleurer pour pouvoir lui offrir mon aide
[Musique]
nous sommes dans la chambre 2520 cette
chambre était louée par un homme
c'était en 1999 7 ans avant ce que John
Wesley a vu sur l'avenue Olivier
monsieur toutes les semaines à peu près
4 ou 5 jours par semaine
il ne passait jamais la nuit il ne
dormez pas ici
une chambre à 15 minutes de chez lui qui
louait à longueur d'année sans jamais y
passer la nuit
pourquoi venir à notre hôtel presque
tous les jours sans y dormir si la bête
ici à Montréal
s'est dérangeant je voulais savoir
pourquoi
la chambre pour avoir un endroit où se
reposer il aurait aussi modifié le bain
en raison de sa maladie
[Musique]
voulait une immense baignoire dans la
salle de bain il a choisi puis notre
ingénieur l'a fait installer
assez frais
c'est en parlant à ses employés que la
directrice de la sécurité de l'hôtel
réalise qu'il se passe quelque chose
mon équipe de nuit me livrait des
comptes rendus donna c'est terrible ses
filles sont si jeunes mais de quoi
parlez-vous
il lui disent voir plusieurs jeunes
femmes montées au 25e étage
je ne pourrais pas te dire combien de
filles par soir
j'ai vu quelques jeunes filles
toutes semblable petite pour la plupart
cheveux foncés de très jolies filles
Donald commence à comprendre le système
ce type Raymond il allait chercher les
filles ou j'en sais rien mais il est
ramené à l'hôtel
Raymond c'est cet homme Raymond poulet
un entremetteur qui travaille pour
Robert Miller
il occupait souvent cet autre suite au
même étage
les filles étaient escortées ici après
elle retournait à la chambre de Monsieur
Poulet ensuite elle quittait
donna le prêt à parler à une seule fois
au téléphone il se plaignait du
personnel de l'hôtel qui dérangeait
Raymond poulet elle en profite pour lui
poser une question
ces filles ne sont pas un peu jeunes
il m'a dit oh non vous ne comprenez pas
ce sont mes nièces j'ai dit vous en avez
des nièces puissiez la raccroché ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est quand j'ai
mentionné que les filles étaient jeunes
il ne m'a pas demandé ce que je voulais
dire il le savait très bien
malgré ses soupçons d'un allopressant
qu'elle a les mains liés les jeunes
femmes qui visitent ne se sont jamais
plaintes auprès de l'hôtel comment
appeler la police quand il n'y a pas de
plainte
j'ai voulu le savoir ça me chicotait
mais qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait faire s'il
n'y avait pas de plainte c'est assez
compliqué
nous avons passé des mois à retracer des
femmes qui auraient connu le système
mailer nous avons découvert que la faire
est plus vaste qu'on le croyait des
femmes nous racontent leurs histoires
qui se passent à plusieurs endroits
entre 1994 et 2006 plusieurs refuges
d'aborder cette période de leur vie
d'autres disent avoir trop peur mais
finalement certaines sont prêtes à
parler
c'était une adolescente en fait
descendre jeunesse
nous l'appellerons Jeanne parce que
comme toutes les victimes elle n'a pas
voulu être identifiée par peur des
conséquences j'ai rencontré Raymond
poulet qui était le proxénète principal
à l'époque pour
[Musique]
couvre la jeune fille de cadeaux et de
compliments le est venu le fait que
j'étais comme plus belle que les autres
plus intelligente que les autres
écoutent
dans le fond la sécurité qui me manquait
Raymond poulet dirige Jeanne faire une
chambre d'hôtel louée par Robert Miller
nous sommes en 1995
on savait pas du tout c'était qui au
départ donc il s'appelait Bob il y avait
aucune photo de lui nulle part on savait
pas que Bob était Robert
[Musique]
Jeanne parle au pluriel car elle n'était
pas seule deux à la fois c'est une des
requêtes fréquentes de Robert Miller et
le mystérieux milliardaire a d'autres
exigences
[Musique]
Félix la vie la première fois il a fallu
que je me lave aussi devant lui puis
fallait vraiment que tout soit bien
propre
je sais qui exigeait des filles souvent
caché le médecin passer des tests de
dépistage des tests de sida parce que en
fait lui il voulait pas utiliser de
Condom mais il voulait s'assurer que la
fille était pas malade
Jeanne dit qu'elle a eu des contacts
sexuels avec Robert Miller à deux
reprises à l'âge de 17 et 18 ans puis
elle est restée dans son orbite elle est
décrit comme un homme ni violent ni
agressif mais obsédé par la nouveauté
Robert il aimait pas coucher avec les
filles très longtemps donc c'est il
fallait qu'il y ait une variété il y
avait une date de péremption sur chacune
des filles puis cette année
Jeanne à côtoyer plusieurs jeunes filles
qui rencontraient malheur grâce à
Raymond poulet c'était pas que des
mineurs au départ parce que dans le fond
il se contentait de ce que Raymond
pouvait fournir je sais que la demande
est venue après le c'est quoi la plus
jeune que tu as vu
je suis assez certaine qu'elle avait 14
ans
je suis assez certaine un 14 ans qui
avait la vieille ou un cap comme non
avec un baby-fays puis des petites
boucles
est-ce que ça se peut que ne savait pas
que c'est impossible ok c'est impossible
qui savait pas que ça démarre que
c'était luminaire
celle qui nous ont confié leur récit
nous disent avoir rencontré Miller dans
plusieurs grands hôtels montréalais ici
ici
ici à l'Intercontinental l'hôtel où
donne à louer
m’avaient dit
je comprends pas pourquoi ça te dérange
que des [__] dans sa chambre des [__]
de quoi tu parles ce sont des enfants
[Musique]
au début des années 2000 quitte les
hôtels c'est cette maison qui sera
désormais au cœur de son système
[Musique]
après la pause des adolescentes
couvertes de cadeaux
les vêtements les bijoux c'était ça on
remplissait des sacs
on peut se demander pourquoi cette
affaire est restée secrète aussi
longtemps une partie de la réponse c'est
la honte des victimes d'avoir dit oui et
d'en avoir entraîné d'autres
voilà des mois que nous découvrons le
système Miller en écoutant celle qui
l'ont connu à plusieurs époques et dans
plusieurs lieux au total nous avons
parlé à une dizaine de jeunes femmes 6
des avoirs des relations sexuelles avec
lui lorsqu'elles étaient mineurs
deux d'entre elles ont accepté de nous
raconter en détail leurs expériences
avec Robert Miller Samantha et Sophie ne
se connaissent pas elles étaient toutes
les deux mineurs à la fin des années 90
[Musique]
la chambre d'hôtel dont parle Sophie
c'est celle de l'entremetteur Raymond
poulet
un filet mignon avec je m'appelle la
sauce béarnaise la première fois que je
mange ensuite c'était vraiment félicite
l'expression
en anglais
je pourrais tellement te présenter c'est
comme tu aimerais parce que c'est
tellement la plus belle puis la plus
intelligente de toutes les filles que je
connais et puis
pitié il me répétait ça et puis insisté
[Musique]
qui connaissait plein de monde
mais j'en avais aucune des mots je
faisais confiance
[Musique]
mais je veux juste prendre mon bain avec
lui
[Musique]
il y avait des dents blanches
blanches blanches blanches
et puis il y avait là comme câble très
calme
puis il me diriger vers le salon
sur le divan
pendant un long moment il montre à
Samantha des photos d'une jeune fille
nue
mais pour Sophie il emploie une autre
stratégie il y avait une de ses amis qui
était une super modèle pour Victoria
Secret
modèle comme elle
dans la suite Sophie est accompagnée
d'une amie celle qui l'a recruté
mais Samantha elle est seule avec Robert
Miller
[Musique]
puis tu vas me laver
je fais ok enfin je lève au complet
et je savais pas le faire
partout partout
même les organes génitaux et tout
[Musique]
il y a décidé de sortir du bain
puis il y a mis son peignoir blanc puis
il me dit
dans la chambre à coucher
[Musique]
je suis couchée dans son lit
jusqu'à ce que je fais
je suis piégée
je me sens pas bien puis je vais
peut-être pas capable de
passer à autre chose
[Musique]
ne proteste pas et la laisse partir
Samantha avec 15 ans
Sophie elle 14
après
une relation sexuelle mais c'est pas
protégé
c'était vraiment
[Musique]
1000 dollars à Sophie Samantha dit
d'avoir reçu cette 150 dollars et les
souvenirs qui vont avec
la pile pour cet argent
[Musique]
je me sens vraiment pas bien j'ai couché
avec un vieux monsieur pour de l'argent
à cet âge-là je comprends que tu l'as
caché tu le dis mais
[Musique]
j'ai donné
sa maison ma famille ce serait pour
poser des questions
surtout d'où ça vient ça
je pensais la presse j'étais comme nous
mais c'est pas un étang
on fait bien
des années 2000 Robert Miller raffine sa
méthode il s'éloigne de Raymond poulet
c'est maintenant son bras droit sa mère
qui va gérer les rendez-vous avec les
jeunes filles ces rencontres n'auront
plus lieu dans les hôtels mais plutôt
ici sur l'avenue Olivier à westmouth
une maison où personne n'habite mais qui
semble aménager pour attirer les jeunes
filles
[Musique]
elles sont plusieurs à nous décrire le
même parcours d'abord un verre d'alcool
du Bélize par exemple
ensuite la descente au sous-sol une
autre jeune femme nous décrit la suite
Julia avait 17 ans à l'époque on allait
dans le sous-sol puis de choisir il y
avait des murs décédés sur tous les murs
c'est un magasin pour nous autres c'est
quand tu es jeune
[Musique]
ensuite c'est l'heure de monter au
premier là où se trouve les chambres
c'est à cet étage qu'après avoir
beaucoup reçu les jeunes filles doivent
maintenant donner
[Musique]
passage obligé à la salle de bain
réservez aux jeunes filles elles doivent
se laver longuement se raser parfois
c'est la dernière étape avant la chambre
de Robert Miller
puis il y avait les sextoys il nous
faisait choisir ce qu'on voulait et
ouvrez les boîtes et imessait avec les
deux filles puis à deux on
s'encourageait un petit peu mutuellement
à être un peu plus forte pour faire ça
mais ça passait relativement vite
avant de partir Robert Miller le remet
des enveloppes avec beaucoup d'argent
entre 1500 et 4000 dollars selon nos
sources elle quitte ensuite avec le
fameux sac de hockey rempli de cadeaux
c'est exactement ce que fait cette jeune
femme filmée par des détectives privés
en 2006
on restait pas très longtemps non plus -
2h en général on était parti
moins de deux heures incluant des
relations sexuelles complètes avec la
plupart de celles à qui nous avons parlé
à ces allégations précises l'avocat de
Robert Miller répond ceci son client
serait impuissant depuis plus de 20 ans
après cette lettre d'un médecin qui
affirme connaître Robert Miller depuis
1996 les mineurs neurologues y
témoignent des difficultés érectiles
très sévères de Monsieur Miller qui
pourrait être dû à sa maladie de
Parkinson
[Musique]
selon nos sources Robert Miller avaient
plusieurs favorites à celle là il
réserve le traitement royal voyage entre
copines avec limousine et chauffeur
hôtel boutique et resto de luxe la vie
de stars tout frais payé à 16 ou 17 ans
mais à 14 ans seulement sophie n'a pas
droit à ce genre de faveur Robert Miller
lui trouve une autre place dans son
système voici ce qui lui propose
que je pourrais me faire plus d'argent
puis que je pourrais y aller vite en
place puis que lui c'était vraiment mon
ami puis qui était et c'était c'était
lui qui allait prendre soin de moi mais
dans tout de suite compris que si tu
voulais continuer à faire des sous
fallait que tu ramènes d'autres filles
qu'est-ce que ça changeait pour toi
d'habitude
c'était avec la fille qui avait des
relations sexuelles pour avec celle qui
avait amené
une grosse partie de la culpabilité que
j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est quoi
d'avoir entraîner
[Musique]
lui-même demandait aux jeunes filles de
présenter des jeunes filles
avec
avec un montant d'argent au bout
donc
c'est une présente une amie je vais te
donner 1000 dollars
à peu près
est-ce que ça faisait partie de la
commande
une jeune fille vierge
soutient que son client n'a jamais eu de
relation sexuelle avec une personne qui
n'avait pas l'âge de consentement
c'est-à-dire 14 ans à l'époque le Code
criminel est pourtant clair tout rapport
sexuel payé avec une mineure est un acte
criminel plusieurs juristes nous le
confirment le consentement de la mineur
est invalide parce qu'elle a été
rémunérée l'avocat de Robert Miller
conclut sa lettre ainsi il n'y a tout
simplement pas de victimes dans cette
affaire hormis mon client si vous
décidez de diffuser ces allégations
fausses et diffamatoires
il y en avait rien à faire de moi
il voulait pas être mon ami puis il
voulait pas m'aider d'enlever puis
tout ce qui voulait
que ce soit moi ou un autre ou n'importe
quel autre
ça change absolument rien
je pense pas que c'est demander une fois
c'est quoi que ça allait d'impact sur
nous
[Musique]
pour une fois
au retour la police va enfin s'en aller
mais ça va mal se passer pour les
victimes
je me sentis comme une merde totale
[Musique]
comment se termine cette histoire que
nous vous révélons enfin par une enquête
policière mais Robert Miller n'a pas dit
son dernier mot
[Musique]
nous sommes en 2006 le détective privé
John Wesley et son partenaire se
présente dans un steak casse de Ville
d'Anjou ils sont convoqués encore une
fois par les responsables de la sécurité
de Robert Miller les deux hommes
cherchent à savoir ce que contient le
fameux rapport de filature c'est leur
troisième tentative et ils vont droit au
but
ils ont dit on vous fait une offre
vraiment c'est quoi
si vous mettez fin à l'enquête et que
vous nous remettez ce que vous avez
besoin de
300000 dollars chacun pour cesser
d'enquêter sur leur client John Wesley
qui sont partenaire André Savard se lève
de table et quitte le restaurant
André et moi on est allé directement à
la police pour leur dire ce qui s'était
passé on leur a présenté nos rapports et
on a dit qu'on ne pouvait rien faire de
plus on ne pouvait pas les arrêter mais
on peut vous donner tout ce qu'on a la
police de Montréal lance une enquête
sans hésiter donne à louer accepte de
collaborer
les enquêteurs m'ont rendu visite
ils ont filmé mon témoignage
je me suis dit finalement ça va arrêter
il va arrêter
en 2009 les policiers débarquent au CH
social de future électronix avec un
mandat de perquisition selon nos sources
la cible est ainsi l'entreprise des
responsables de la sécurité de Robert
Miller leur bureau sont à la même
adresse la même année Robert Miller est
convoqué au poste de police il est pris
en photo avec ses acolytes pour
permettre aux victimes de les identifier
ces photos nous les avons obtenues
d'abord un Robert Miller visiblement
contrariée puis Terry corporel et
l'ex-policier Steven Roberts les deux
détectives privés qui travaillent pour
lui et Raymond poulet notre metteur sur
Linkedin il a aussi un autre titre
conseiller personnel du président chez
Future électronique
finalement sa mère le point de contact
avec les jeunes filles son poste
officiel vice-président directeur chez
Future
[Musique]
j'étais seule à la maison le smoke
et ça cogne à la porte de chez moi et je
vois que ce sont des policiers
les enquêteurs ont des questions à poser
aux présumés victimes de Robert Miller
et Sophie sent qu'elle n'a pas le choix
de répondre et voulait que je leur parle
de
ça sinon y aller m'arrêter moi
pour avoir tenu un résultat
à 14 ans et 15 ans exactement
[Musique]
au moment de l'enquête Sophie travaille
depuis plusieurs années elle a fait de
longues études et laisser son passé
derrière elle rien de tout ça ne semble
ébranler les policiers
on s'en fout de l'ange que j'avais que
je serai jugé en adulte et puis que
j'aurai des peines d'adulte puis que
c'est ça dans le fond moi ma carrière
c'est pas grave
j'étais complètement Flavie c'est
que
j'ai compris que j'avais pas trouvé le
choix de collaborer avec eux je me
sentis le comme une merde totale
comme dans le fond le tout ça c'était
tout de ma faute à moi
ils ont presque traités comme des
criminels ils sont venus chez nous il
fallait faire des empreintes digitales
prendre nos photos profil face je veux
dire on est des victimes là-dedans donc
quand agis comme ça
avec des victimes c'est hyper intimidant
moi j'ai rien raconté
ou peu parce que tu avais peur moi
j'avais peur
j'avais vraiment peur
Jeanne s'inquiète parce qu'un homme
qu'elle connaît à peine l'accompagne au
poste de police il fait la même chose
avec plusieurs autres jeunes femmes
Robert avait fourni un avocat
aux filles c'était le même avocat pour
toutes les filles
puis
il nous suivait dans la salle
d'interrogations son rôle à ça
qu'on parle pas
Sophie elle a tout déballé mais ce ne
sera pas suffisant personne ne sera
accusé de quoi que ce soit dans cette
affaire
de ce qui se passait il y a pas personne
qui m'a appelé à part pour me dire que
il y aurait pas d'accusation de porter
on aurait pris que le dossier d'enquête
a traîné quelques années sur le bureau
du procureur
il n'y a jamais eu de procédure mais ils
ne l'ont jamais dit
je ne comprenais pas je suis peut-être
naïf mais je suis du genre à croire que
si tu en feras la loi et tu dois payer
pour ça comme je ne comprenais pas
alors j'ai dit aux détectives et ça je
m'en souviens quand vous trouverez un
procureur qui a des couilles
rappelez-moi
parlant d'appel nous contactons ceux qui
sont soupçonnés d'avoir aidé Robert
Miller à bâtir son système est-ce que je
peux parler à Raymond poulet s'il vous
plaît
vraiment poulet refuse notre demande
d'entrevue
nous avons aussi appelé les détectives
de Robert Miller
deuxième message je vais vous rappeler
au stock possible c'est un avocat qui
nous a répondu par écrit il n'y
vigoureusement les allégations contre
Terry cortan Stephen Roberts
oui bonjour est-ce que je peux parler à
ça
nous avons aussi rejoint Sam et Brahms
au bureau de futur électronique Android
[Musique]
il qualifie l'ensemble des allégations
de fosses et malicieuses et il rappelle
que l'enquête criminelle a été fermée
sans qu'aucune accusation ne soit déposé
moi je pense que ce réseau là il y avait
juste un client c'était lui
je vois pas comment être à la tête de ça
mais pourquoi personne n'a parlé avant
maintenant ça fait 20 ans et plus la
plupart des filles qu'il rencontrait
savaient pas c'était qui lui donc c'est
difficile à ce moment-là d'aller porter
plainte contre quelqu'un qu'on sait même
pas c'est qui c'est
25 ans plus tard malgré tout ce qu'on
sait maintenant sur le consentement la
manipulation les pièges tendus à des
jeunes filles mineures malgré mis tout
aussi
Sophie continue de s'en vouloir
[Musique]
quoi que ce soit
ils ont été rémunérées
[Musique]
qui sont peut-être en train d'écouter
les missions à la maison puis qui ont
vécu la même chose que toi puis qui ont
peur de parler
porter plainte
Bob c'est Robert
[Musique]
on a demandé des entrevues au SPVM et au
Directeur des poursuites criminels et
pénales qui n'ont pas souhaité
s'exprimer mais qui promettent
d'examiner attentivement toute nouvelle
information dans ce dossier qu'on va
évidemment suivre de près c'est tout
pour nous au nom de toute l'équipe merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]